they would like to thank the members of
the jury for focusing on the evidence in
this trial rather than on the rumor and
innuendo that have followed this case
from the outset
this is the second time that Mr Mendy
has been tried and found not guilty by
the jury
he is delighted that both jurors reached
the jury's reached the correct verdict
was guys inzaman Rasheed is at Chester
Crown uh court and is about we saw you
moments ago walking alongside Benjamin
Mendy what was he saying
nothing to say from the former
Manchester City footballer he walked
free from Chester Crown Court after a
jury found him not guilty
for those charges of attempted rape and
rape and he walked free back to uh his
car and he's driven away and now I'm
sure he will be focusing on trying to
get back onto the football pitch he will
want to be playing football once again
that was uh his aim but let's just talk
about what's happened today this has
been a three-hour deliberation from the
jury they were sent out uh just before
11 o'clock this morning and then just at
three o'clock about an hour or so ago
they came back with those verdicts and
those verdicts of not guilty for uh
attempted rape and a rape those two
charges that were brought towards
Benjamin Mendy in this retrial after
other sexual allegations in a previous
trial were dismissed now um the French
International fullback the former
Manchester City footballer was cleared
of six counts of rape and one count of
sexual assault after the court case here
back in January and as he came out of
the courtroom today he was in tears
um crying his eyes out hugging his
friends and acquaintances who had been
at the court with him today and his
lawyers has said on his behalf that he
would like now like to rebuild his uh
his his life and return to essentially
what is Top Flight football he's at the
age of 28 he's still got a few years
where no doubt he can get back playing
he's mixed out on a lot he's missed out
on Manchester City this season winning
the treble he's won a few titles with
the club he's missed out on playing for
his uh his National side as well the the
French team of course but he will want
to try and get back onto the football
pitch now they also said
um on his behalf it's been almost three
years since the police started
investigating this matter Mr Mendy has
tried to remain strong but the pro
process has inevitably had a serious
impact on him so after a retrial
Benjamin Mendy has today been cleared of
allegations of attempted rape and rape
allegations which were brought forward
which allegedly the women say took place
as his Cheshire home is multi-million
pound Cheshire mansion He has today been
cleared of those charges and he walks
from Chester Crown Court a free man and
a footballer hopefully hoping to try and
get back onto the football pitch and
reinstate his career